e aí
o renato me arrumar e colar mais um
review sido chega do lado de cá é o
preto cambinda que vem trocar amigo um
beijo se usar chicote mito é mais
vantajoso aquilo que deixou sua realeza
da costa da mina usei uma pobreza
trabalho forçado muito tabu dançará em
junto o suor meio-dia no sol trabalho
forçado um cabo deixado tirou sua bunda
criança é
a mera mão um olhar aceso tudo tão
diferente é foque seu rito seu canto
muito sua origem na cor salvo na sungar
e pede a salvação para o rei dessa nação
é mais por causa de um aquilo que deixou
sua realeza da costa da mina presinho a
pobreza trabalho forçado local deixada
enxuga o suor meu dia no sol trabalho
forçado nunca mais olhos do nosso amigo
inteira do sol tempero toninho gente
magoa
o saco da chamou calor um número eu
impetração ver que morreu na sua
priminha arrumar aranha para ler preto
preto preto 1
e aí
olá bom dia a todas
bom e se você é homem é uma pessoa você
também pode responder bom dia a todas e
sobre a vida a pele preta sou cantora
caruaruense agrestina nordestina
brasileira da américa latina e tô aqui
para conversar um pouco com vocês sobre
como eu entendo que a militância pode
ser uma importante estratégia para a
educação libertadora como falou paulo
freire o nosso maior patrono da educação
é a minha relação com a música vem da
minha casa eu cresci numa cristão
protestante e minha mãe e meu pai
cantavam no coral da 1ª igreja batista
aqui de caruaru posteriormente primeira
igreja batista de bonito a música era
muito presente tanto nesse contexto da
igreja quando fora desse contexto já que
eles eram formadas em história e a
música era uma importante ferramenta
pedagógica na construção de suas aulas e
eu já achava isso incrível porque eu
entendi que a música
e ela tinha uma outra função para além
do entretenimento e que a partir da
música a gente podia transformar
estruturas sociais e aí eu trago a
memória as minhas primeiras referências
musicais dentro de casa fora desse
contexto cristão
e caetano veloso gilberto gil zé ramalho
um disco de gal costa que eu gostava
muito porque ela aparecia com o cabelo
bem volumoso na capa e enfim jurava
identificação vocês imaginam porque né
eu fui crescendo e fui ouvindo essas
músicas e fui entendendo que eu também
podia cantar apesar de ser muito tímida
a princípio hoje eu ainda carrega um
resquício de timidez embora ninguém
acredite é e aí eu comecei a cantar na
igreja posteriormente sair da igreja é
embora tem um respeito muito grande pela
igreja que me formou enquanto cidadão
cristã e porque eu tinha uma referência
paternal é que apesar de ser evangélico
tem uma visão muito crítica das coisas
então a gente entende a bíblia de uma
forma diferente
é do que o que estava posto na igreja
era muito mais amplo inclusive na
construção da própria imagem de jesus
enquanto homem preto e africano distante
do que foi construído pela igreja
católica como todas e todos aqui sabemos
é e aí aos 21 anos eu comecei a cantar
profissionalmente morei muitos anos em
bonito voltei a morar em caruaru e fui
chamada para fazer o primeiro show e a
construção do repertório já era de um
viés muito político eu trazia
comportamento geral gonzaguinha e trazia
devia maravilhoso de caetano veloso e aí
futuramente eu pude começar um trabalho
autoral que também seguiu essa
a linha de raciocínio né dessa
construção da infância e entender que a
música tem uma função política e que a
música foi super importante no processo
de derrubada do regime militar aqui no
brasil e não à toa que existia censura
né e a gente tem visto também nos nossos
dias é formas às vezes sutis às vezes
nada sutis e continuar silenciando a
arte ea cultura eu aprendi algumas
coisas na escola
o que só vieram a fazer sentido ou
deixar de fazer completamente sentido a
partir da ministração dentro de um
movimento social chamado marcha mundial
das mulheres é um movimento
internacional surgiu no canadá amazonas
2000 e que tem uma representação bem
forte aqui no agreste né eu posso falar
da realidade de caruaru que é onde eu
faço meu ativismo e a massa veio me dar
entendimento é da política da política
que me chegou a partir do contato com
meu pai com a música que eu ouvi ali né
e de entender que muitas vezes o viés
que a escola toma para educar por
exemplo sobre sequestro das pessoas
negras que vieram de áfrica para o
brasil e que foram extremamente
exploradas e que continuam só
e dessas mazelas da colonização até hoje
é um modelo que precisa urgentemente ser
desfeito né aquilo que se chama de
escravo precisa de um nome que seja
muito mais justo nessas pessoas foram
escravizados são a sexualidade foi
negada sua identidade foi negada seus
cantos foram negados seus ritos foram
legados o próprio conceito de
sincretismo religioso precisa também ser
superado porque o sincretismo era uma
estratégia para que as pessoas negras
pudessem cultuar seus santos a partir da
imagem dos santos instituídos aqui no
brasil
ah e hoje a gente precisa superar
e essa ferramenta enfim essa estratégia
do sincretismo porque ela não mais
funciona para que as pessoas possam
finalmente finalmente ter direito de se
reconectar com a sexualidade de retomar
a história que eles foi tomada também
também a partir da religião
i e ii
que foram coisas que eu já questionava
em quanto criança mais que entrando na
marcha mundial das mulheres a minha
consciência e contra a mulher negra fez
muito mais sentido porque eu fui uma
criança que durante muito tempo não me
reconhecia enquanto mulher negra quando
olhava no espelho porque a gente foi
muito
o marginalizado e continua sendo
marginalizado até hoje né então os
nossos cabelos foram atacadas é a nossa
cor foi extremamente atacada né e quando
a partir do processo do teatro
inicialmente e por fim dentro da marcha
mundial das mulheres eu entendi que eu
preciso ter orgulho porque essa cor fala
de resistência esse cabelo fala de
resistência né fala da gente ter
resistido quando o plano era que a gente
fosse dizimado né a partir do processo
da imigração europeia é a ideia era que
os negros deixassem de existir e mais de
500 anos depois nós estamos aqui eu tô
aqui em cima desse pau contando uma
história para vocês né e dizendo que eu
acredito de verdade que a escola tem uma
função muito importante e essencial
e são de cidadãos e cidadãs mas eu
acredito também que alguns modelos e
algumas rotas precisamos ser receitas de
forma urgente inclusive porque algumas
narrativas precisam ter finalmente voz
dentro do modelo educacional
especialmente a narrativa do povo negro
e dos povos indígenas né e isso esse
entendimento não teríamos chegado
distante de da trincheira que representa
o movimento social eu sei que tem muita
gente aqui provavelmente que faz seu
processo e militância ali na internet
que estuda mas está organizado dentro de
um movimento social fala também sobre
estratégia de sobrevivência sobretudo no
contexto de país em que pensar diferente
pode ser extremamente perigoso
ah então está organizada dentro da
marcha me ensina também a sobreviver a
poder estar aqui e poder falar
politicamente entendendo que o espaço
para além do samba para além da dança de
modo geral para além da música existe
que é o lugar de fala de construção de
ideia politicamente entendendo que a
escola cumpre uma função mas que o
movimento social se agregado ao processo
escolar pode trazer uma outra amplitude
de sentidos para quem para o que a gente
aprende ali dentro da sala de aula
inclusive para entender que existem
outras possibilidades de leituras de
leituras de escuta musical de dança
distante do que está posto ali na escola
entendendo que é possível sim ler maria
carolina de jesus djamila ribeiro
o leon sales entendendo que essa soares
podem depois de anos refazer sua
carreira de forma autoral cantando
politicamente elevando
representatividade para as mulheres
pretas de periferia e eu convido vocês a
imprimir em um propósito em cima disso
que vocês vão tanto fazer em cima da
educação e eu tenho certeza que todos
têm até porque no brasil é impossível
educar sem ter um propósito contando com
todas as dificuldades que a gente
enfrenta em conta educadores e
educadoras mas se para além do espaço da
sala de aula que é tão estratégico
existe alguma outra coisa que vocês
gostem de fazer e que vocês possam
colocar um propósito e que isso também
possa ser inserido no processo de
educação no processo pedagógico convido
a fazer eles porque todas as
dificuldades ganham um peso menor
e quando a gente entende que a gente tá
ali transformando estruturas sociais
transformando indivíduos em dívidas e
inspirando para que essas pessoas também
sejam transformadores e transformadoras
de estrutura social
e aí
a virar um para a vida pelo ventre pelos
poros pelos cabelos do sovaco virar
virar pelas mãos pela pulsação da pélvis
pelo movimento das asas virar pelas
palavras pelas palavras surrada cê
gritados pelas palavras ditas não de
tratadas
[Música]
a virar um a sabedoria um a coragem que
diz pirar pelas unhas pelas garras pelo
plano e pelos alto pela beleza da
olhando a outra olhar para si a
revolução virar virar que eu vi tirar
virar kelvin virar virar que eu vi
podemos ir virar virar kelvin virar um
pa vida pelo ventre pelos poros pelos
cabelos do sovaco virar fi
as mãos pela pulsação da pélvis pelo
movimento das asas
o virar pelas palavras pelas palavras
surrada se gritados pelas palavras ditas
não deitadas
se virar com a sabedoria com a coragem
kids virar pelas unhas pelas garras pelo
pão e pelo salto pela beleza que olhando
a outra olhar para si a revolução virar
virar que eu vi virar
a gente pode fazer melhor
a pirar pira
ó e virar virar kelvin virar virar que
eu vi eu vi virar
e emanando virar virar kelvin kelvin
virar virar kelvin virar
[Aplausos]